okay so let's go back let's go back and
try it let's
let's let's go through this thing
chronologically
you have the the flinstone credit card
printer
you're you're just starting to get into
low-tech making the plastics low-tech
what so what starts happening after that
uh i started progressively making a
little bit more money
and i was able to uh slowly just start
upgrading
every piece of equipment to make a
better product
okay that so that that was kind of like
i say about a year it took about a year
really to get going to
really get like the the good equipment
you know to where i could make
a credit card that looks like it came
straight from the bank and when i got to
that point
i was like okay i kind of knew like i
didn't have the clientele yet but i knew
i had the product
i knew i had the product right you know
were you
honing in like the design of these cars
the templates
yeah the templates everything had to be
right i mean i had to figure out how to
make the visa logo because there's like
there's holograms and [ __ ]
built into these cards yeah that's
pretty technical the way to design them
yeah
chinese guys yeah how did you do that uh
the hologram issue
i found a dude in china yeah i found i
found a dude in china that owned a
printing company and i basically
the alibaba uh i was alibaba or was it
um
i know five or one or something like th
gate
that's still around oh they're still
cranking holy [ __ ]
uh so yeah so i found a dude on there
and i cut out
um a credit card i cut one out of like a
real credit card and then i mailed it to
him to china
and i was like can you can you do this
for me and i was like i sent him he's
like send me a sample
and i sent it to him and i think like
six weeks later i got like a roll of
like 5 000
visa and mastercard holograms heat press
hollows
damn yeah yeah and then once i had those
it was a wrap
because i i mean my graphic design game
is pretty dope
so yeah oh yeah it's yeah i'm i'm a
wizard with that [ __ ] i've always have
been
you know it's just something that i've
just always been natural with and um
so yeah i mean once i did that and once
i had that the holograms and once i had
the actual physical product made once i
figured out how to make the visa logo
once i had figured out how to do the sig
strip on the back the signature strip on
the back because that's like a whole
thing and then there's like this
rear indent embossing i had to figure
that out so
there was hurdles and it took it took a
while it took like six or eight months
before i had
like a verifiable certifiable like you
know a product that you just couldn't
shoot holes in there's no way
it would be completely indistinguishable
from a regular credit card yeah if you
put your
from bank of america and you put mine
next to it there'd be no difference
there'd be no difference
that's [ __ ] crazy man yeah
so so what are you doing with that so
now now you're making these credit cards
and you're selling them on these forums
or what
i started using them okay first okay
because i
didn't test them out yeah to you know
just to see do test runs
and um flying colors you know nobody
even bat an eyelash i never had
one issue number one single issue maybe
a couple declines
you know just because the dump
information wasn't um
probably you know good or whatever but
yeah yeah so i was using them and then i
figured out okay let me get on the forum
and i was already dealing with people on
the forum from buying buying dumps and
buying um
you know buying plastic and stuff like
that so i just i talked a few of my guys
on the forum and i had to get you know
they had to vouch for me
but since i had already been on the
forum for a year and a half two years
that wasn't a really big deal you know
and i was on two or three different
forums so uh like i was
pretty well known in the community you
know it's just like you sound like a
popular screen name
i did yeah us plastico u.s plastic
that's what probably in in the long run
that's what probably got me [ __ ]
was trying to be clever and you know
what i mean oh you're trying to brand
yourself i was
i was thinking you know but i shouldn't
i should have just been like you know
anonymous or whatever but
um so i think that's that's but you have
to stay consistent on that scam
in that scam world though right i mean
people have to know who you are to be
able to trust you yeah it's like a
double-edged sword yeah
and like i said i had two years in at
that point and i knew all the the major
players in the game and i knew who was
doing what just from being on the forums
and you know being on irc
yeah yeah yeah
okay so what happens next uh my products
got better
sorry did you did you already meet
millwall man at this
no memo man came memo man came after i
got on to um dark market
okay but i wasn't on uh no that was
carter.su
i met melmo man and that came later that
came you know that was probably towards
the very end like
at the very pinnacle of my career if you
if you want to put it that way elmo man
yeah melmo man was the dude who opened
up all the doors for me
in the in the in the karting world he
really he had all the he he knew yeah he
plugged me in
so you still at this point at this point
you got the guy from china
who who printed thousands of these
holograms for you for your credit cards
yeah you had these [ __ ] rock solid
fake credit cards that you made yeah
but you still had like a long way to go
before you reached
your peak oh yeah yeah well i had no
clientele
okay i had no clientele and um it took a
while it took maybe six months
to build to build trust in the community
and to build clientele
so thousands of these credit cards
you're literally taking these little
holograms
and you're physically like placing them
on each of these credit cards with your
hands like hand by hand
each one each credit card each card how
long does that take
how long does it take to do one card oh
i had it down i could
print one card in less than five minutes
i could print
everything it stick everything onto it
yeah well yeah see
i would already have all the i would
already have all the the templates lined
up in photoshop
okay like ready to go all my windows
open bom bom bom bom bom
you know what i mean and then i would
load maybe like 10 or 15 cards in the
printer and i would be like okay
print in sequence print one print two
print three print four print five
so then it would it would run out all
the cards print them front and back
you know what i mean it would put the
put all the only thing i really had to
do myself was
emboss and do the hologram so i would
have to physically place the hologram
myself and use a heat press
to adhere it to the plastic and then i
would have to
to manually emboss the card myself and
this is before i got the auto embosser
where i could just throw them in
and do a batch and it would you know run
a 50 or 100 at a time
damn yeah so when i got down when i got
really efficient at it i could
maybe do 100 cars in an hour about an
hour i could print
hologram and emboss about a hundred
close to 100 a thousand cards in a day
yeah easy yeah yeah yeah if i'm cranking
away but then you know sometimes you
have problems
the printer starts gets too hot and
starts [ __ ]
melting cards and printing [ __ ] sideways
you know so you've always got little
issues
right yeah like that you gotta deal with
but yeah i can do a thousand cards in a
day what's the most cards that you did
in a day you think
that i've manufactured in one day
i think i've done about 800 six between
six and 800 in one day
you know on a good day if everything was
going right and i had all my equipment
operating
properly yeah okay so how did you
start getting this getting this out
there on on
online or on these black market on these
uh on the dark web and start getting
customers to buy shitloads of them yeah
so
so the initially the first uh carter
forum that i was on
i went ahead and i just made my first
post here i am new vendor
right um here's my product you know you
post pictures it's like a whole well it
was like a whole thing not anymore and
then you know i would get maybe like one
or two orders a month
you know and then once those orders came
in and like people started leaving
positive feedback it just
kind of snowballed after that and then
i remember the day because i would only
get maybe one or two orders but i
remember the day i woke up
and i checked i think i checked one of
my emails and i had 15 or 20
20 orders waiting for me and i couldn't
believe it how much per how much
a thousand dollars one order is a
thousand dollars yeah for how many cards
uh 100 100 cards yes 20 a card 100 cards
two drivers or you get i'd make ids for
you however many you wanted
and then i would do i think it was like
100 cards embossed
everything encoded numbers
and ids and ids yeah holy [ __ ] but i
wouldn't make 100 ids obviously i'd make
like two or three
okay you know or whatever that whatever
they wanted but i mean you know so
there's a cap on that so the ids have to
obviously correspond with the credit
card
exactly yeah yeah because say you go to
a store and you make a purchase
um and it's over like three or four
hundred dollars
like a lot of stores like people don't
realize this but a lot of stores like
say best buy you go to best buy you make
a purchase over 300
they ask physically ask for your card
and they physically take your card
and they they go on their pos machine
now their pos machine the point of sale
service machine
won't let them process the sale unless
the
four digits on the front of the card
match what's actually encoded to the
card
so it's like it's like a security ship
so what they do is they take the card
and they punch the numbers into the
computer
because you've already swiped it so
they're going to punch these numbers in
and if these numbers in the front of the
card don't match what's being swiped
it's automatic fraud
you know what i mean yeah so you have to
have the corresponding plastic
to match the to match the numbers and
you have to have the id because they're
going to ask for
for id because a i don't have the
people's pin number so you're not
processing it as debit
you always have to process it as credit
even though it's a debit card
got it so they have to have id when you
process anything for credit they always
ask for id always especially if it's a
big purchase
right you know huh louis vuitton you go
to louis vuitton and try and buy
a 2 000 handbag on a credit card they're
going to ask you for id right right 1
000
yeah you know even if you even if you go
in there look in the part they're still
going to have they always ask for id
right you know so you have to have the
id to match the card everything has the
jive the numbers everything has the
to be coherent okay so is there a
minimum number of cards they had to buy
for one order so is the minimum 100
minimum it was a thousand dollar minimum
order okay so it was a hundred cards and
then i would work with them
on the ids like whatever they wanted
okay because those were easy
cool so that's good money you're making
a couple you're getting a couple orders
a day making a couple things
i was doing like one or two orders a
month and then like i said i woke up
that one morning and i remember i had 20
orders waiting on me and i couldn't
believe it
one morning you just had 24 20 waiting
on me yeah yeah i remember that date
distinctively
yeah i couldn't believe it i was running
around the house jumping off the [ __ ]
furniture dude
yeah i couldn't believe it i mean 20
grand that's a lot of money for for
somebody who doesn't have [ __ ]
and for somebody who's been getting
robbed and pouring all their [ __ ]
every dollar
they've had into this [ __ ] for the past
two and a half years and not going
anywhere
you know so to me this was victory this
was
you know i made it right so what else
are you doing in the meantime besides
i mean obviously you're just sitting
online like you have your info sitting
online for people to order
and there's only so much time you're
spending making these cards what else
are you doing
i was doing some online carting i was
doing some some virtual
virtual carting i was doing virtual
carting i was still going in stores here
and there
and you know mind you i wasn't spending
any money at this time either because i
had cards
if i needed a gas i would go [ __ ]
fill up with a card at the gas station
if i needed groceries i would take a car
to the grocery store and buy 300
in groceries you know so all my money is
basically just going in a [ __ ] shoe
box in the closet and i'm not really
spending any of it
yeah and at this point in time i had
been living off a credit card stolen
credit cards for probably three and a
half years
like i didn't have a job for three and a
half years i was just using
stolen credit cards for everything where
where were you living
uh at this point i was in coral springs
okay did you pay your rent with the
credit cards
oh well i would just go if like when
rent time would roll around i'd go grab
a laptop or two laptops
get cash just cash it out go pay a
thousand dollars for rent or whatever
yeah yeah
wow dude what a [ __ ] life how old
were you
early at this point early 20th 20 000 or
20 000
order early 20s yeah about 25
twenty five